so how you guys do today how was your
WonderCon going it's been great have a
little did you get any chance to you
know like walk around see anything or if
you guys should have been like running
from interview to any of you he did a
quick look at the exhibition hall I
don't know about you Barney but uh I did
get to walk right through the exhibition
hall it was super cool though because I
got to wear glasses aren't you wearing
glasses glasses it was so weird
we had an escort and they were like they
can't know who you are so I wore a hat
and sunglasses that it never felt so
more important in my life I made two
thousand four hundred forty dollars
selling photographs of the three of them
no one wanted to buy them because they
know they're bad these are decent people
[Applause]
it's interesting cuz you guys you know
you make the show and you you hope it
gets a good response and you release it
to the world and wondering what it's
like to see such a you know a
concentrated reaction like this to see
it all like this is it people like the
show and they want to tell you about it
right now I mean it's awesome and this
is what's the best thing about
conventions I mean you get to just put
all like all this fandom in one room and
you know John Josh and me we're huge
Crotty kid fans and to be in that room
and see people who are not just fans of
the original movie but fans of Cobra Kai
and they're shouting out you know Hawk
and Miguel and you know it just like it
gives us goosebumps it's great I'm
wondering what you took away from making
season one that you wanted to bring into
season two because I feel like season
one the response was so immediate and
gigantic did you take any of that or did
you have a plan that you kind of stuck
to we've had a plan sort of from the
beginning we know where we want the show
to end the plan evolves over time we're
just we're just continuing to do what
we're doing and we're thrilled with the
reaction I mean it's it's bonus away
that people have reacted as as
passionately as they have so we're gonna
give them a lot more of what they want
and maybe a little bit of what they're
not expecting
and certainly a lot more fighting I'll
tell you that music well let's let's
talk about the fighting I kind of want
to hear from the people in front of the
camera did you did you sort of prepare
for that from season one or is there
anything new for you that you were like
I don't know how I'm gonna pull this off
there there are a couple of tidbits in
season one and season two that were
definitely hard to pull off like in
season two especially just the the sheer
fact that you're raising the stakes
before even looking at any of the
choreography I always I knew that they
were gonna be parts that we're gonna be
hard but uh going into it are our
wonderful stunt coordinator and trainer
he Dakota and and Janelle Curfman they
do such a great job at training us that
there was never a moment where I was
like I can't do this it was always like
even though I know that this is gonna be
hard these guys are gonna make it happen
and for that I thank them it's a lot of
stretching yeah in all things yeah lots
and lots of stretching so but so thanks
to that I'm able to you know kick people
in the face so it has near-misses
problems pulling punches anything like
that yeah making this show is horrible
it sounds like making these shows
horrible they oh yeah it's horrible no
it's a lot of fighting a lot of we're
moving really fast too
we did the Karate Kid we had three
months to train to get ready for each of
these fights these fights some of them
are getting thrown together then the day
before sometimes sometimes on the spot
and you have to be really stretched out
like the guys are saying and we have
amazing trainers keeping us in shape and
ready for that and yeah we've been added
we had you know some of these are really
physical though I mean I think a lot of
us get you know some bruises here and
there you know yeah I walk around with a
bruise on my arm I think I pulled a
groin III had a mild mild mild
concussion by tackling somebody on a mat
you know so you know very mild I think
but it's super exciting a lot of
action-packed and we are great hands
with heat oh and Janelle the trainers
are amazing and the stunt team that they
pull around us too these guys are
amazing martial artists and an N stun
men so it's awesome I want to talk about
that from your perspective I'm kind of
curious how you make sure the fights
aren't
fights like they're telling a story
through the fights and wondering how you
keep that well that's the thing we never
start an episode saying okay you know
we're gonna have this fight start things
off in a way that then it's all about
just the fight the fight has to come at
an inflection point for a character or a
group of characters that it can only be
solved by a fight or oh they're
resolving that with a fight and at that
point if the fight has story stakes and
it has character stakes where you're
bringing a level of emotion into that
fight whether you agree with both
parties or you really want to see
someone win and they lose at least you
know that the fight has stakes then we
write the best we can for three guys who
have never taken a karate class in our
lives and and we talked extensively with
hito and Jenelle in terms of how do you
stage that fight in a way that is
awesome
1ups the fights we've done before is
true too the martial arts that either
side might be learning and for is
achievable in the ridiculously short
window of time we usually have to to get
that fight but yeah first and foremost
it really it really has to feel like if
this were a conversation between these
characters the outcome would be the same
it really needs to feel like we went
through this fight because they needed
to say something and sometimes saying
something is with your foot or your fist
I'm definitely wondering what the return
of crease means for the show and I'm
wondering what it was like to step back
into that role after all these years
well I step back into that role because
of them you know I mean the the the
conversation we had at a restaurant and
they said we'd like you to come in
episode 10 set up season 2 and I said
why can I come in episode 6 you know and
they said because you you know you're
gonna set up season 2 and the the
comfort zone that we're in with this
show is because of them the three
writers here producers what they say
they mean what happens in their
perception really happens as actors
working with people
like that the time elements involved the
complication of the characters the
evolution of the characters it all
really happens the way they tell you the
way they persuade you to believe that
they're telling the truth that's why I
signed on and I wanted an evolution of
this character and I've got it
and I want more but in short and
seriously if it's real it's just and it
is rare in Hollywood you get that I've
been around a long time it's rare that
you get the truth with talent and more
energy than you have to make it happen
it's been I mean that's the thing that
we were most looking forward to about
season 2 all throughout season 1 we knew
that we were gonna you know bring sense
a crease back and that he was gonna play
a major role in the second season and we
know that for fans yeah this is just one
of the most iconic villains of all time
there's not a lot of moments in the
Karate Kid movies where you see the soft
lovable you know side of crease it's
always you know this threatening
foreboding presence and that gave us a
great place to really you know just you
know take this character that we all
love and learn more about that that
person in a way that's still gonna keep
everything that you like about crease
there but but like kind of like like
with Johnny and the first season make
you look at the original movie you know
with with new eyes
and I'm wondering and this this goes for
william ii in stepping into the role
after all these years are you are you
thinking about it differently other
things stepping into this characters
mindset are there things you definitely
weren't thinking about the first time or
is it sort of like you learned with the
character after all these years I love
that you gave me the mic you know you
know for me you know there was two
pieces of the of The Karate Kid when I
read the screenplay that I connected
with Johnny the first was the very
opening scene he's on the motorcycle he
says I'm an X degenerate I have one year
make it work and that was like okay so
he's trying to make things work and then
the end when crease tells him to sweep
the leg he doesn't want to go in the
ring and then the third thing when he
hands Daniel the trophy and says you're
all right Larusso so I saw a kind of a
goodness in him and I saw a soul and
Johnny Lawrence besides just being
villain the bad guy I saw he's he's you
know he's got a he's been led astray and
he kind of wakes up at the end of The
Karate Kid through the crane kick in a
way Miyagi saves Johnny in a sense you
know and then increased chokes him out
in the parking lots well those it almost
kills him but that's the core of who
Johnny is he's trying to make it work
and and you know he's the kind of a good
sport you know trying to be but now here
he is again he's the same guy he has the
same soul so stepping into that was very
natural to do but then the guys created
his environment and his circumstances in
a way that completely put him in a
pressure cooker that was a lot of fun
and and I had to work through and you
know he's on the bottom trying to trying
to make his way he's still trying to
make it work all these years later so
that's been thrilling and really natural
plus they there's 30 years from The
Karate Kid 2 now and his life has a lot
of happenings have happened along the
way and the one thing he really wants
right now is his son and his son wants
nothing to do with him and then he meets
Miguel who he helps and it invert n't Li
kind of saves and becomes his sensei and
now this is all spawning off and he's
opened up the Pandora's box for him he
opened up the Cobra Kai which is a snake
that bit him and I always said from the
very beginning like why is he going back
to Cobra Kai you know like well we're
about to find out
you know the head increases back so
daniel could just leave well enough
alone if daniel never show but you
wouldn't have a show that's right and we
have a show i mean the bottom line is
that the evolution of this character
which should have gotten an emmy last
year you know the evolution of that
character is so interesting and creative
I would never have assumed over all
these years and we've always been
playing with scripts Billy and I how to
create parati kid how to bring it back
be arrogant enough not to use our names
because everybody knows who we are you
but it we never got it together and they
got it together for us and two simple
things that my character cares about he
cares about Johnny Lawrence as as my son
that I never had and he cares about
Cobra Kai and I think what the what the
audience needs to learn about this
season is which one works which one
evolves which one wins and I feel like
the show brought back a sort of like
real earnest martial arts storytelling
which isn't something that you see a lot
of they used to be a lot more martial
arts movies martial arts TV shows and
I'm wondering what and this for all of
you I'm wondering what you think the
modern entertainment is missing without
that that that genre being so prevalent
that's really it I mean I mean and
that's the thing that that this
generation needs badly is an awesome
montage yeah they're a weak character
learns to get stronger faster you know
by running up a hill or picking
something up or sweater well I think
Mohawks were the thing that was really
missing and amazing well I thank you
guys so much for coming in and I'm so
excited for season two and congrats on
everything for people to check it out 24
thanks